mad in America is a critical look at the
treatment of the mentally ill in the
united states other robert whittaker
talks about the business and science of
treating and caring for the mentally ill
over the last 300 years he spoke
recently in Cambridge Massachusetts for
just under two hours in Madden America
bad science bad medicine and the
enduring mistreatment of the mentally
ill medical journalist robert whitaker
reveals an astounding truth
schizophrenics in the united states fare
worse than those in poor countries and
over the past 25 years outcomes for
people with schizophrenia in this
country have worsened indeed Whitaker
argues modern treatments were severely
mentally ill put factors such as
management and costs ahead of the
comforts and needs of the patients
tracing over three centuries of quote
cures for madness Whitaker shows how
medical therapies and drugs have been
used to silence patients and dull their
minds deepening their suffering and
impairing their hope of recovering based
on exhaustive research called from old
medical patient records o patient
medical records historical accounts and
government documents this haunting book
raises important questions about our
obligations to the mad what it means to
be insane and what we value most about
the human mind Publishers Weekly called
Madden America rich and Curtis review
said it offers a quote scorching
indictment of the status quo it sure
packs a wallop Robert Whitaker's
articles on the mentally ill and the
drug industry have won several awards
including the george polk award for
medical writing and the national
association of science writers award for
best magazine article he was a finalist
for the Pulitzer Prize for a Boston
Globe series on harmful research
involving the mentally ill that he
co-wrote in 1998 a series that led him
to write this book please join me in
welcoming robert whitaker
first thank you all for coming out on a
night like this I very much appreciate
it I thought that rather than read from
the book at all I'd basically just talk
about some of the themes that are raised
by madan American by this history and
and also I'd like and the question that
this that this history raises for all of
us as a society i also want to leave
some time for questions afterwards
because this subject tends to be a very
controversial one and it provokes rather
strong emotions as Nancy mentioned I
became interested in this subject about
four years ago while reporting on abuses
of psychiatric patients in research and
while I was doing that story I kept
coming upon outcome studies that I find
that I found at that time quite
mind-boggling and they were of two
swords one was a study by Harvard
Medical School researchers in 1994 which
found that outcomes for schizophrenia
patients in the US had declined over the
past 20 years and we're now no better
than they were in 1900 when the therapy
of the day was to wrap the insane in wet
sheets which is rather mind-boggling
when you think of course we have these
sort of modern care modern drugs etc it
just didn't fit with everything that I
had read about schizophrenia in the past
the other were two studies by the World
Health Organization in the 1970s and
1980s the World Health Organization
twice did a comparative studies of
outcomes in developed countries versus
developing countries and what they found
each time was that outcomes for
schizophrenia patients in the developed
countries this is us and seven other
well-off countries were markedly worse
than in the poor countries such as India
Nigeria and Colombia and what they found
in those poor countries was this
spectrum of outcomes which you'll find
very surprising in the foot in the poor
countries they found about forty percent
of patients who suffered a schizophrenic
break basically recovered in a period of
say 1 to 2 years and were basically
unempowered at the end of that period
another twenty-five percent of patients
might have had a second or third
psychotic episode but each time they
remitted to the point that they
recovered their full what was called
premorbid status which means
they were functioning as well as they
were before they ever became ill and
then about a third became chronically
ill whereas in the US and other rich
countries the overwhelming majority
became chronically ill and you did not
see the same pattern of recovery now the
World Health Organization did not
identify a reason for this variable in
outcomes they looked at various factors
like Social Care family integration that
sort of thing but they really couldn't
identify any factor that could explain
this amazing difference in outcomes
however they did look at they didn't
make a mention of the difference in
medical care and what they found in the
poor countries is that only one in six
patients was regularly maintained on
antipsychotic medications whereas in the
rich countries in the US and other
countries that of course is the
cornerstone of care continual medication
now that does not prove anything in and
of itself that the medication is the is
the variable that is the problem however
it is suggestive that there may be
something going on over the long term
that that the medications are causing a
problem over the long term I will say
this to the World Health Organization
concluded after went back on the second
study that it said living in a developed
country was quote a strong predictor
that a person with schizophrenia would
never recover which is a rather amazing
finding so my thought was it with this
book was basically to explore this
failure to do so through the prism of
history to basically trace the history
of medical treatments since the colonial
days and see if there's any sort of
story that evolved that would explain
this modern-day failure now the roots of
mad medicine in English cultures goes
back to the 1600s and the 1700s when
English doctors set up commercial mad
houses where they would take you know
people suffering from delusions
psychosis and people that frankly family
members families often just wanted to
get rid of and they started publishing
medical texts with saying that they had
ways to cure or treat the insane and the
competition in fact was so fierce at
this time by
into the 1700s many of these medical
writer these doctors were saying that
will cure the insane or you get your
money back it was very much a commercial
enterprise now at this time in these
medical texts they basically conceived
of the insane this was the age of reason
by virtue of having lost the reason as
having descended to the level of brutes
to an animal-like status and so the
medical therapies that they developed
were basically in in response to that
conception of the mentally ill so for
example you can read in the medical
texts where they advise occasionally
whipping the mentally ill in order to
instill fear and obedience they also
would bleed them very aggressively purge
them very aggressively and this of
course would also weak in the mentally
ill and make them more manageable
another form of therapy that was popular
in the late 1700s was the spinning chair
they would rotate the mentally ill very
violently they would become nauseous and
sick and again you could see how this
would indeed week in patients make them
less likely to be disruptive that sort
of thing so in a sense you could say
that they worked finally them one of the
more bizarre therapies of the day in the
late 1700s was a sort of drowning
therapy and what they would the advice
was that you would hold the patient
under water until they lost
consciousness and then hope then you
would bring them back up and hopefully
revive them and the thought was that
maybe a new personality would emerge at
that time so these were the teachings
that were bait employed at the first
hospital in American Pennsylvania
Hospital in the late 1700s when the
physician that oversaw the care there
was named Benjamin Rush he was the
preeminent physician of the day and of
course he basically employed these
teachings because they were seen as the
medical wisdom of the times a rush also
invented his own novel therapy called
the tranquilizer chair it was a wooden
contraption that basically held the
person very firmly he couldn't move a
muscle and he would keep the patient in
there for an extended period of time and
rush boasted that his wooden chair could
in fact assist in curing madness I'll
just read
quickly of how he wrote about this
device of his it binds and confines
every part of the body by keeping the
trunk erect it lessens the impetus of
blood toward the brain by preventing the
muscles from acting it prevents the
force and frequency of the pulse and by
the position of the head and feet favors
the easy application of cold water or
ice to the former and warm water to the
ladder its effects have been truly
delightful to me it acts as a sedative
to the tongue and temper as well as to
the blood vessels in 24 12 6 and in some
cases in four hours the most refractory
patients have been composed I call it a
tranquilizer now rush was a good man
empathetic towards his patients and he
believed this chair was in fact a
biological remedy for mental illness or
for madness and here's why he believed
it was so he believed that madness was
caused by too much blood rushing to the
brain and therefore the chair by
confining all parts of the body by the
arms and the legs would prevent blood
from going to the brain and therefore
caused the brain the blood to pool in
the feet and that by applying ice to the
head he was also cooling the brain as
well so he saw this was a way to
basically ameliorate the problem of too
much blood rushing to the brain now we
read of this therapy today and of course
we think oh it's cruel and absurd and
ridiculous well in a way again it did
work if you kept a patient in this chair
for 24 hours it did weaken them they
were afraid of the chair and as one
European doctor subsequently wrote this
invention by the way was exported to
Europe and it became quite popular there
anyway as one European doctor
subsequently wrote the chair would quote
make the most stubborn and irascible
patient gentle and submissive now during
the 1700s the English public often
wasn't so a keen on these very
aggressive therapies that were being
peddled by the mad doctor's and often
said we need a reform of some sort and
the reform was led by the Quakers in the
1790s under the guidance of a man named
William toque and what the Quakers
believed is this idea that the mentally
ill were animals was wrong and that what
we needed to do what they needed to do
was consider them as brethren and treat
them as such
so what they set up was basically a
home-like shelter for the mentally ill
with the idea that if you provided them
food and shelter and empathy and
basically held up a mirror to them that
said to them you have the capacity for
behaving well and capacity actually for
getting control of your mind that this
sort of environment this nurturing
environment could indeed assist nature
they would say in helping the mentally
ill get well and I'll just read a brief
bit from their shelter that they opened
in 1796 the Quakers opened their small
home in 1796 it was a simple place with
gardens and walks where the ill could
get their fill of fresh air they fed
patients four times daily and regularly
provided snacks that included biscuits
along with a glass of wine or Porter
they held tea party tea parties at which
the patients were encouraged to dress up
during the day patients were kept busy
with a variety of tasks sewing gardening
and other domestic activities and given
opportunities to read write and play
games like chess poetry was seen as
particularly therapeutic the Quakers
borrowed their medical philosophy from
the ancient wisdom of Aeschylus soft
speech is to distemper Drath medicinal
the therapeutics of the English mad
doctors wrote Samuel took Williams
grandson in 1813 were those at which
humanity should shudder the one medical
revenue regularly employed at the York
retreat was a warm bath which was to
last from 20 minutes to an hour if it be
true Samuel took reasoned that
oppression make a wise man mad is it to
be supposed that stripes stripes meaning
blows and insults and injuries for which
the receiver knows no cause are
calculated to make a madman wise or
would they not exasperate his disease
and excite his resentment may we not
hence most clearly perceived why furious
mania is almost a stranger in the
retreat why all patients were closed and
are generally induced to adopt orderly
habits now the first such moral
treatment asylum in the US was opened by
Philadelphia Quakers in nineteen in
nineteen 18 17 and soon others appeared
in other cities along the eastern
seaboard here in Boston immoral
treatment asylum opened in 1821 and this
came to be known as McLain
means now this form of small Asylum care
which was known as moral treatment
meaning tending to the emotions was
basically the the standard of care for
about 35 years in the United States and
historians who've gone back and looked
at the results have found that it did
indeed produce fairly good results they
found that more than fifty percent of
patients the newly insane who entered
these asylums each year would be
discharged within the course of 12
months in the best long-term study that
was ever done involving more than 1,000
patients found that more than fifty
percent of those patients never relapse
to the rest of their lives so we see in
moral treatment basically in this
distant history some evidence that a
nurturing environment and many of the
things that we all need to remain well
and healthy comfort friendship shelter
food etc can indeed help people restore
people to good health the downfall of
moral treatment i rana CLE enough came
as the result or somewhat as a result of
the activities of an activist named
Dorothea debt dicks she had suffered a
breakdown of her own early in her life
and she'd gone to England where she had
basically been nurtured to health by
back to health by some Quakers and been
exposed to their philosophies and so she
came back to the United States in the
1840s and wanted to make it her life's
work to expand this form of care so it
was available to the population at large
in the United States in the earlier days
the smallest sign was largely catered to
a fairly well-to-do clientele and
response to her please in fact the
United States the state's responded with
a great generosity there was a wave of
asylum building so much so that the
number of mental hospitals in the
country increased from 18 and 18 42 139
in 1880 the problem was as these asylums
were built two things happened one
patients with all sorts of disorders
were basically dumped into the asylums
people with syphilis alcoholics the
senile elderly were all put in these
asylums they also grew greatly in size
the idea with moral treatment was you
needed to have a very small place
no more than 250 patients where there
could be a direct interaction with a
doctor and as role you ended up with
these bleak warehouses housing a
thousand or more of more patients and of
course people with syphilis and the
senile elderly no longer got well and so
moral treatment came to be seen as a
failed treatment by the end of the 1800s
now the next prominent turn in our
country's care of the mint al took hold
in the first decades of the 20th century
and this really i think is one of the
real dark periods of our history one
that we as a country I think have never
really gone back to revisit and I think
we actually should this was when the
eugenics movement took hold in the US
now we usually think of eugenics as a
movement we associate it with Nazi
Germany but actually eugenics was a
movement first nurtured here in the US
and was first here in this country that
state policies that were enacted based
on eugenic beliefs now eugenics arose
out of Darwinian understanding of
evolution that species could evolve over
time and if you believe that then the
thought was a human race Elisa's this is
what the you Genesis argued could
improve itself in this way it could
encourage those with good genes to
reproduce and it would discourage those
with bad genes from reproducing with it
the idea would be you would actually
prevent those with bad genes from
reproducing now this of course raises
all sorts of problems about who has good
genes and who has bad genes and of
course the agenda secane from the ruling
class and so the movement in the US was
very much led by graduates and frankly
academics that such schools as Harvard
Yale Princeton it really was the ruling
old Yankee elite that pushed this agenda
in the United States well what did that
mean for the mentally ill with a
mentally ill oh of course were seen as
having the worst genes of all and they
were targeted as a group that in essence
needed to be done something about their
their genes that they were passing on
now the thing that first thing that
happened is a eugenic scientist started
publishing articles claiming that
insanity was indeed a genetic dis
order so much so that by around 1915 you
could read in medical texts that
insanity was passed along it was a
single gene disorder and passed along
much like eye color was and once that
became the accepted wisdom of the day it
became the foundation for various
policies designed to keep the mentally
ill from from reproducing the first was
we passed laws and this I think every
state passed this law prohibiting the
insane from marrying the second thing
that we did is we started the idea was
that the mentally ill in fact needed to
be segregated into asylums and so
instead of putting the mentally own to
hospitals where the hope was they would
get some care that would help them heal
and then they would be as discharged and
you know go back into the community the
goal really was became to keep them
there until they passed reproductive age
and indeed you start seeing from 1900 on
through really the 1940s use the
discharge rates go way way down and you
started seeing people spending their
whole lives in the asylums well that was
a social policy that wasn't a reflection
of the illness itself and finally what
happened of course was States started
passing laws authorizing the forced
sterilization of the mentally ill the
first such law was passed in nineteen oh
seven twenty years later the US Supreme
Court ratified such state laws is
constitutional and by the end of
nineteen fifty in that first 50-year
period there were some around 50,000
Americans so forcibly sterilized with
about half of those mentally ill
patients the other group that was really
targeted for for sterilization was the
mentally [ __ ] as they were called at
a time now it's interesting to note two
things in 1933 Hitler came to power and
one of the first things his government
did was passed a forced sterilization
bill and at that time the Nazi
government said we are going to
sterilize 375,000 mentally ill patients
in our country over the next few years
well it's telling us terms of the tenor
of the times in the US that that was
widely affair Lee widely applauded in
the US as a
aggressive health measures so for
example the new york times ran an
editorial supporting the nazi bill the
New England Journal of Medicine also ran
an editorial praising it as a
progressive humanitarian health measure
and it just shows how basically societal
beliefs can really affect how what our
beliefs in terms of how the mentally ill
should be treated finally it's
interesting to it's important to note
during this time in 1920's 1930's the
rhetoric that was directed by you
genesis tanned you Genesis the eugenics
movement really was had the support of
the majority of Americans was incredibly
harsh towards the mentally ill you heard
them you'd hear eugenics New Genesis
rights and talk about the mentally ill a
social wastage as poisonous slime as
cancers on the body politic leading
scientists talked about how they were a
species of humanity that needed to be
exterminated it is really spined it is
chilling stuff to read and night and in
fact there was some discussion about
whether or not the mentally ill should
be killed in 1921 i believe it was
Connecticut briefly debated the
possibility of a mercy a law for the
mercy killing of the mentally ill which
was reported upon any new york times as
if this was a possible rational thing to
consider and in fact in 1935 a Nobel
Prize winning scientists at rockefeller
institute for medical research New York
City Alexis Carrel wrote about this very
explicitly he said that the insane and i
quote should be humanely and
economically disposed of in small
euthanizing institutions supplied with
proper gases this was published by the
way by a mainstream publisher so it
wasn't considered that outrageous now
was during this eugenics era during the
late 1930s that for therapies arrived in
Asylum medicine that were of a rather
peculiar sort these were insulin coma
therapy metro zoo convulsive therapy
electroshock and prefrontal lobotomy
now in the media these were all Harold
is wonderful breakthrough treatments for
mental illness that there were now cures
for mental illness however once you got
the away from that public facade and
listen to what the psychiatrist and the
neurologists were talking about it
became becomes quite clear that they
worked in a very specific way and in
fact what the psychiatrist at the time
openly acknowledged is that they worked
by inflicting a sort of brain trauma on
the patient and in fact they were
sometimes dubbed collectively brain
damaging therapeutics now for instance
insulin coma therapy works by depriving
the brain of sugar and that's why the
person went into the coma they found
that this sometimes caused brain
hemorrhages and in some instances it did
indeed lead to death Metro's ole was a
very powerful poison about a minute
after it was injected the person would
go into a convulsion so severe that at
times they would break bones many
suffered spinal fractures they shattered
their teeth muscles sometimes even
pulled away from bones it was a horrible
awful treatment electroshock was
initially developed as a method to
induce seizures in a more controlled way
than with Metrozone so it was really
just seen as a mechanism for doing that
interestingly also when they studied
electroshock therapy in the 1940s they
said it produced a trauma that was very
akin to closed head injury ie concussion
now what doctors found with this is that
after one such treatment patients would
emerge of a bit dazed lethargic and
therefore quieter and easier to control
in the asylums but however once they
began to recover from this trauma of
course they're agitated behavior and
delusions might return so the form of
care they they then settled on was that
you needed to run patients through this
form of treatment whether it be insulin
coma treatment or Metrozone convulsive
therapy or electroshock numerous times
30 x 40 x 50 times with the idea that
this trauma would basically take hold
and finally produce a more lasting
change and the idea was that after
30 40 50 times the person would become
less self-conscious less frankly there
was they talked about a reduction in
intelligence in fact I'll read a quote
from a well-known psychiatrist that time
dr. Abraham Myerson as to why they saw
this as affecting a cure quote I think
it may be true that these people have
for the time being at any rate more
intelligence than they can handle and
that the reduction of intelligence is an
important factor in the curative process
I say this without cynicism the fact is
that some of the very best cures that
one gets are in those individuals whom
one reduces almost to a mensia I mention
means like simplemindedness now lobotomy
was sick was seen and properly so as the
most precise way to basically effect
this change in being now when the
surgery began to become popularized in
the 1940s there was a lot of research
being done on frontal lobe function and
what scientists at that time knew quite
well and understood quite well is that
the frontal lobes were the part of the
brain that most distinguished us from
from primates and other animals primates
of course have frontal lobes but ours
are much more pronounced and they
realized that frontal lobes were sort of
the seat of self-consciousness it's the
part of the brain that allows us to
worry about ourselves fret about our
futures care about ourselves and so the
surgery in essence was disconnecting
because what you did in front of la
Baronne frontal lobotomy was basically
disconnect the frontal lobes from the
rest of the brain and so the surgery in
essence was attacking the very part of
us that we we think makes us most human
and here is how Walter Freeman who was
the biggest promoter of lobotomy in the
u.s. described the change wrought by
lobotomy after the lobotomized person
unable to form a mental picture of the
self would no longer worried about past
or future here's what he wrote he is
freed from anxiety and from feelings of
inferiority he loses interest in himself
both as to his body and as to his
relationship and as to his relation with
his environment no longer carrying
whether his heart beats or his stomach
churns
or whether his remarks embarrass his
associates his interest turn outward and
obsessive thinking is abolished there is
something childlike in the cheerful and
unselfconscious behavior of the operated
patient so that was the change that was
seen as good at this time in 1943
investigator reviewed all the lobotomy
bottome operations done to date there
had been more than 600 at that time and
he concluded that doctors had reported
that the surgery had improved
eighty-four percent of patients who
underwent it and that fewer than one
percent had in any way been harmed by
the surgery after that report appeared a
lobotomy was seen as a very much
accepted medically proven therapy the
number of a lobotomies exploded in the
media treated it as a miracle sort of
surgery surgeons were said to be Wizards
that could meet me pluck mental illness
from the brain and in 1949 the inventor
of this surgery a Portuguese neurologist
by the name of e-gas Moniz actually won
the nobel prize for lobotomy so it's
something that is rather remarkable
today now the modern era of treatments
for mental illness really can be traced
back to the introduction of Thorazine in
1954 Thorazine was brought along as a
drug initially for use in anesthesia and
what it could do it could numb the
nervous system the central nervous
system without causing people to lose
consciousness and this was seen as
important for surgery it became it was
introduced into Asylum psychiatry after
physicians noticed that it also made
people apathetic less alert and slow in
their movements the first psychiatrist
in fact praised it for producing a
change similar to that seen in lobotomy
they called it a pharmacological
lobotomy now you have to realize at that
time that was seen as a good thing and
understandably so I mean in 1949
surgical lobotomy won the nobel prize in
medicine so if you had a pill that could
now effect a change in beingness what
was somewhat similar it only made sense
that that would be seen as a better way
to do it
today we know how Thorazine and other
drugs of this type which are called
standard neuroleptics by the way they
work exactly what they do to the brain
these drugs all block dopamine receptors
in the brain they block a particular
type of dopamine receptor known as the
d2 receptor now dopamine as you most of
you probably know is a very key chemical
in the brain it's in terms of how the
brain communicates with itself and these
drugs basically block seventy to ninety
percent of the d2 receptors now what is
what does that do to a person this this
what change does it affect what really
affects a person in three pronounced
ways first the basal ganglia is an area
of the brain that very much relies on
dopamine there are three areas of the
brain that very heavily rely on
dopaminergic neurons so obviously we're
going to see change in function related
to those three hours of the brain the
first is the basal ganglia which is
responsible for the initiation of motor
movement in the control of motor
movement now you get Parkinson's disease
when you lose about eighty percent of
the dopaminergic neurons in this area of
the brain so in other words you're only
functioning at about twenty percent of
normal and that's when you get the
shaking symptoms so of course what
happened when you block seventy to
ninety percent of the dopamine receptors
necessary the brain with Thorazine you
get some problems with motor movement
you get parkinsonian symptoms so you
know in reality it's not right to say
that the parkinsonian symptoms are a
side effect of these drugs they in fact
are a direct effect of these drugs it's
a straight one if they do what
parkinson's disease does they the same
sort of pathological deficiency in
dopamine transmission now the secondary
of the brain that really relies on
dopaminergic neurons is the limbic
system the limbic system is an area of
the brain where we basically respond
emotionally to the world it's how we
feel the world it's also important for
mounting emotional responses to the
world so it relies on dopaminergic
neurons as well so you block this from
transmission and patients often say well
they feel sort of emotionally cut off
from the world they feel like zombies
and that's why because you're blocking
the limbic system from really its full
activity
now the third part of the brain that
relies on dopaminergic neurons is indeed
the frontal lobes for example in animal
experiments if you turn down the or
basically shut down the dopaminergic
neurons they'll say it's the same thing
as surgery surgically removing the
frontal lobes so that's why you get
these comparisons between a chemical
lobotomy in a surgical lobotomy with
standard neuroleptics because again
you're creating sort of the same gaming
of function in the frontal lobes so
that's what the drugs do and that became
somewhat clear it's quite clear today
but it became very clear by you know
even in the late 50s that the drugs were
dampening down dopamine transmission to
a very severe degree now in terms of
judging the merits of these drugs
there's really a couple ways to look at
it the first is how did patients feel
about these drugs that subjective
response now one of the things that I do
think has been a horrible mistake over
the past 50 years particularly when
standard neuroleptics were the drugs of
choice there wasn't a lot of listening
to the patients and how they responded
to these drugs and you know the
subjective experience means a lot and it
means I mean obviously that is critical
and now some patients at least seem to
respond okay to these drugs said it made
him feel the more tranquil and more calm
but a more common response was that they
described it as they very much resisted
it they found it painful to have their
dopaminergic system shut down in this
way they felt separated from the world
as if by a glass screen they complained
of feeling like zombies and there was a
biological reason for that now their
complaints actually they brought their
complaints to us to the senate in 1975
in a very interesting hearing the senate
was holding the hearing because
neuroleptics were being used in very
many settings in juvenile delinquent
settings with the mentally [ __ ] and
the thought was you know there's this
overuse of the drugs but it was the
mentally ill who really stepped forward
to describe what it was like to be on
these drug
and they talked about how frankly it
produced the worst misery how that left
them feeling mummified and and you know
sort of not alive and I want to just
read real briefly testimony from a woman
who testified at that hearing named
Janet got gun because I think it's one
of the most articulate descriptions of
how many people felt on these drugs I
became alienated from myself my thoughts
my life a stranger in the normal world a
prisoner of drugs and psychiatric
mystification unable to survive anywhere
but in a psychiatric hospital the
anxieties and fears i had lay encased in
a Thorazine cocoon and my body heavy as
a bear's lumbered and lurched as i tried
to maneuver the curves of my outside
world my tongue was so fuzzy so thick i
could barely speak always i needed water
and even with it my loose tongue often
could not shape the words it was so hard
to think the effort was so great more
often than not i would fall into a
stupor of not caring or i would go to
sleep in eight years I did not read an
entire book a newspaper or see a whole
movie I could not focus my blurred eyes
to read and I always fell asleep at a
film people's voices came through
filtered strange they could not
penetrate my Thorazine fog and I could
not escape my drug prison the drugs made
me constipated as well as ravenously
hungry as a final misery they caused me
to gain weight for eight years I took
laxatives and suffered as I watched my
body grow heavy and distorted my hands
shook so I could barely hold a pencil
and I was afflicted with what dr. stern
field lightly called dancing legs a
parkinsonian side effect of these
chemicals for this I took a drug called
Q matron and if I missed a day or a
dosage my shoulder muscles would tighten
into excruciatingly painful knots and my
legs would go on wildly out of control
these drugs are used not to heal or help
but to torture and control it is that
simple now interestingly drugs were
condemned at the Senate hearing for use
with the mentally [ __ ] and for the
elderly nursing homes however the person
who chaired
birds by said however we are not
concerned about their use in the
mentally ill when it's been used in the
mentally ill after a proper diagnosis so
basically the Senate carved out an
exception saying that while other people
might experience this these drugs in a
difficult fashion the mentally ill it
was okay to use them with them shortly
after that the mentally ill did mount
some court challenges I saying that they
wanted the right to forego treatment
they somewhat won those challenges it
became sort of a due process issue that
psychiatrists could still take patients
to court and get a court order to allow
force treatment it's interesting the
argument that was made in response to
the patient's court challenges was that
the mentally ill being sick didn't
understand that they were sick and
needed these drugs and while there may
be some truth that the people in the
midst of a psychotic delusion aren't
judging themselves well again that's a
response that somewhat negates their own
experience and it is interesting at this
time during the 1970s that the Soviet
Union was using these same drugs on its
dissidents basically to break their the
will of its dissidents and their
dissidents were complaining quite loudly
about how miserable these drugs made
them feel now that was really a
subjective response to the drugs the
next question is what is the research
literature show and remember we started
this talk about why were outcomes worse
in the United States and other developed
countries where these drugs were used
continuously as opposed to the poor
countries of the worlds were only one in
six patients were still kept on the
medications and the research literature
is actually quite surprising I mean I
was stunned as I began to trace this
forward the study that established the
efficacy of neuroleptics was conducted
by the nm ni-mh that's the National
Institute of Mental Health in the early
1960s and in a six-week study they found
that indeed patients treated with the
drugs they're psychotic symptoms abated
more quickly than the symptoms in the in
the placebo group
and in 1964 they made a big statement
saying that these drugs are quite safe
and in fact it looked like it infected a
cure in about fifty percent of patients
in a six-week period and even today that
is a study still often cited as really
establishing the efficacy of the
neuroleptics but what happened when the
ni-mh went back a year later and looked
at the fate of the patients at one year
follow-ups and what the ni-mh found at
that time was that the group never
exposed to the drugs the placebo group
had a lower rehospitalization rate than
any of the drug treated groups there
were actually four arms in the initial
study three groups received a
neuroleptics one group was a placebo
group the placebo group had a lower
rehospitalization rate than any of the
three drug treated groups so here you
have the first sign of a bit of a
paradox that you have drugs that can
indeed dim symptoms over the short term
but may be causing some sort of
long-term chronicity in in psychosis
well after that in the next couple years
there were several other studies with
some other unsettling news researchers
noted that it seemed like relapse wall
on medication ended up was more severe
than a placebo relapse the
symptomatology was worse than if the
nanos never exposed to the drugs they
also ran a drug withdrawal study in
which they took everybody off the drugs
and they found and they did to such
studies that relapse rate rose in direct
correlation to the dosage that the
patients Ron the higher the dosage they
were on before withdrawal the greater
the incidence of relapse now what all
this suggested what this began to
suggest was that the drugs were exacting
some change in the brain that over time
actually paid be made people more
biologically prone to psychosis than
they would otherwise naturally be now
this in the 70s actually led to three
very interesting studies funded by the
NIH one of which was led by Lauren Moser
who at the time was the head of
schizophrenia studies at the NIH so he
was basically at the top of you know
prestige in the country for
schizophrenia research
and in each of these trials what they
did is they randomized patients upon
initial treatment into non-drug and drug
treatment arms now the non drug
treatment arms did get psychosocial care
of some sort they just didn't leave him
untreated and now in each of these
studies the non drug treatment group the
group treated without drugs actually had
fared better over follow-up periods that
range from one to three years they had
lower relapse rates and they also had
better sort of social outcomes as well
and what was really pretty remarkable
and I think as we go forward with the
question and answer period is in each
instance more than fifty percent of the
patients treated without drugs in fact
recovered and didn't relapse at all
during the relapse periods [ __ ] the
follow-up periods that extended as long
as three years now by 1979 Canadian
investigators had basically explained
what was going on and why the drugs were
making people more prone to psychosis
over time more biologically prone and
this is a little bit of a confusing
story it's one I don't think that's
really it's been really kept hidden from
the American public but i think it's
sort of critical to really understanding
why this you see this long-term
chronicity if you remember the drugs
dampen down dopamine activity and
powerfully so well in response you know
what I let me just batch it because I
how this evolved how this unfolded is
really interesting initially the
investigators understood that the drugs
block dopamine activity so they
hypothesized while schizophrenia must be
caused by too much dopamine activity an
over activity of dopamine in the brain
and that's why you started hearing in
the 70s all these drugs are like insulin
from for diabetes people with
schizophrenia have too much dopamine
activity in the brain this dampens it
down and it's sort of normalizing brain
chemistry that became the hypothesis so
now how did they but that was a
hypothesis now they had to investigate
to see whether that was true now the
first thing they looked at was whether
neurons in the brains of people with
schizophrenia were putting out too much
dopamine and the way they check that out
was they looked in their blood and urine
cerebrospinal fluid from metabolites of
dopamine these are the breakdown
products and to see if there were
unusually high levels of the metabolites
and what they found is that prior to
being medicated there were no such
higher levels of metabolites now after
medication you do briefly get an
increase in metabolites and that's
because in response to the dopamine that
the drugs blocking dopamine the brain
actually tries to compensate and starts
pumping out more more dopamine but that
only lasts for a few weeks the second
thing they then looked at they have
hypothesized well okay the neurons
aren't putting out too much dopamine
maybe the problem is they have too many
dopamine receptors and that they
therefore are hypersensitive are
super-sensitive to dopamine and
initially it seemed like they had found
indeed that they looked at autopsy
brains at autopsy they found that people
with schizophrenia had maybe fifty
percent more dopamine receptors than
normal and there were some exclamations
and pronouncements that the cause of
schizophrenia apparently has been found
the problem was that if you read the
original research the researchers said
but we don't know if this is caused by
the drugs or not we need to look at
unmedicated skits people with
schizophrenia be prior to medication and
we also need to do animal studies of
this sort what they found is that indeed
prior to medication there was no extra
there will no there weren't they did not
have an extra number of dopamine
receptors but what happened was in
response to medication again trying to
compensate for this dampening down of
dopamine the brain what the scientific
term is upregulated or increased its
number of dopamine receptors and so
basically the drugs created the very
pathology that was hypothesized to cause
schizophrenia in the first place I doubt
if you've heard that very often in in in
the popular literature and this was
basically understood by 1979 and
Canadian investigators had publicized
this and and they wrote and it came
forth with this conclusion which is
rather a stunning moment I think in the
history of our care their names were
geese you nod and Barry Jones they wrote
and I quote neuroleptic neuroleptics can
produce
dopamine's supersensitivity that leads
to psychotic symptoms an implication is
that the tendency towards psychotic
relapse in a patient who has developed
such as super sensitivity is determined
by more than just the normal course of
the illness now the other thing that is
thought to be caused by this increase in
dopamine receptors is tardive dyskinesia
tardive dyskinesia hits about five
percent of patients on standard
neuroleptics each year and its
cumulative so for example you'll see
five percent of patients begin to suffer
from it after one year ten percent after
two years fifteen percent after three
years and what sort of dyskinesia it's a
more permanent form of basically brain
dysfunction loss of motor control you'll
see the tongue sort of rhythmically
moving in the mouth to see other sort of
muscle lack of motor control of muscles
when they've also studied you it's also
associated with some cognitive
impairments and the reason it's
permanent is because even after the
drugs are withdrawn you also owe you
often don't get a remission of these
symptoms so this was all quite clear but
in 1970's now since then there has been
virtually no exploration of non-drug
alternatives in this country however a
few european investigators have run such
experiments and each time they have
reported good results in switzerland for
example in 1992 they ran such an
experiment and they concluded that
patients treated with no drugs or low
drugs had significantly better results
in better social outcomes Sweden ran a
such a study in the 1990s as well they
found that about half of patients first
episode patients so treated could do
well without neuroleptics and overall
the experimental group that was treated
in this manner and the manner was this
they would try to treat people without
neuroleptics if some people weren't
doing well then they would play someone
neuroleptics and that was experimental
group versus a control group that was
immediately put conventionally all under
lept Ock's and they found that this
experimental group treated in this sort
of selective manner had lower rates of
hospitalization use and overall fared a
little bit better and finally finland in
the year 2000 also conduct us an
experiment of this sort and they found
that for
four percent or forty three percent in
fact did not need neuroleptics over two
year period fared well and that overall
this experimental group that was treated
in this selective manner some people
were they would try not to place people
on neuroleptics right from the get-go or
otherwise use low dosage that this
experimental group generally did as well
or better than a group treated in a
conventional manner the final piece in
this puzzle was put in place by
investigators at the University of
Pennsylvania in 1998 they reported that
MRI scan showed that in respond that MRI
scan showed that after you put place
people on these standard neuroleptics
you got an enlargement of the basal
ganglia over in an 18-month period and
that this enlargement of this area of
the brain was indeed associated with a
worsening of both positive and negative
symptoms positive symptoms are the
psychotic delusions the hearing voices
that sort of thing the negative symptoms
are social withdrawal lack of social
integration and what they found is that
is this enlargement which indeed is
visible on MRI scans over an 18-month
period indeed correlated with the
worsening of symptoms so we started this
talk why we're outcomes worse in the US
and other developed countries than in
the poor countries of the world and I
think you can see that with these old
drugs anyway there's a fairly complete
picture we you see for example the first
long-term study greater rates of
hospitalization we know the biological
change caused by the drugs that make
people more biologically prone to
psychosis we also know that change is
associated with tardive dyskinesia which
is a form of long-lasting or permanent
brain dysfunction and finally we even
had we also have six different studies
randomization studies where the the
group treated in a selective matter with
neuroleptics did as well or better than
the conventionally treat a group and
finally we have the MRI scans showing
this enlargement of an area of the brain
associated with a worsening of symptoms
so that's I believes and as is it an
explication of the puzzle of the poor
outcome studies
that were documented by the World Health
Organization now I was doing a radio
interview yesterday Wisconsin Public
Radio and someone came on and said I
yeah you're right but that's old news
you're beating a dead horse and in a way
she's right because in the way from the
public if you go into meetings with
psychiatrists and read their literature
they basically confessed in the early
1990s that these old drugs really had
not done at all well in terms of
producing any sort of good quality of
life that you had a very poor quality of
life with standard neuroleptics and so
we got into 1990s a new class of drugs
called atypical drugs and they came to
market with much fanfare heralded as
much safer and more efficacious than the
old drugs and you also got stories such
in the New York Times with a new
explication of what was the cause of
schizophrenia the new york times
reported that the cause of schizophrenia
now was too much dopamine activity and
too much serotonin activity and these
new drugs basically alleviated
schizophrenia because they helped
balance both of these well there is in
fact no evidence that schizophrenia is
caused by too much serotonin activity
that was just something to an
explanation that fit the new drugs what
the new drugs do is block both serotonin
and dopamine activity they they do
indeed they don't block dopamine
activity as profoundly as the old drugs
they don't clamp down on that d2
receptor with nearly the same force
which is a good thing patients clearly
do not find them as physically painful
as the old drugs and in that way much
more tolerable now what I did for this
book though I was still curious because
of course if you go through the history
of mad medicine there's always been a
cure I mean it's been one thing after
another that the latest treatment has
always been said to be that with a
wonderful break through it basically has
occurred time and time again and so I
wanted to see what was the actual
clinical data from the clinical trials
that was submitted to the FDA and how
did the FDA what did it think of these
new drugs and what the FDA concluded in
its review was that the trials had been
biased by design by the drug companies
to make the new drugs look better than
the old drugs now that does not mean
that the dune drugs may not be better
than the old drugs it just meant that
the science that was done to test them
was basically fought and they had
basically created a story using trial
design to make the new drugs look better
the other thing that was clear from the
FDA data was that they were more
problematic than the public had been led
to believe so for example in the Wall
Street Journal there was a report that
there had been basically no severe side
effects adverse events with risperidone
one fact if you looked at the clinical
day data risperidone is one of the new
drugs by the way about one in 30
patients in those clinical trials
suffered a severe adverse event which
meant either life-threatening or needed
hospitalization and you saw this with
the other drugs as well their work there
was complications there were plenty of
adverse events problematic adverse
events what happened was though the side
effect profile is different with these
new drugs than with the old drugs that
that's clear and on the new drugs I have
no idea whether they're going to lead to
better outcomes they may I mean our
native so I think that's absolutely
wonderful terrific and great my
complaint about the new about the
science behind the new drugs is in fact
that the testing wasn't rigorous and
wasn't unbiased and so it's left us in
the dark about what the side effects may
be and in what way they may be better
than the old drugs there are some good
things i think happening in the country
today round these drugs and around
medication use i think one of the great
things we're seeing is in the old days
with the standard neuroleptics all just
you basically saw research that was
designed to look at did it did it
diminish the psychotic symptoms there
was very little look at what was it
helping people lead good lives was it
helping them go back to work was it
helping them have friends that sort of
thing there does seem to be new to a new
paradigm emerging new talk emerging that
we need to keep our sights set on
recovery that's not it's not just enough
to knock down psychotic symptoms I think
that is tremendous it's one of the most
hopeful things I think that is going
right now
it's it's really a wonderful development
and in line with that what you are
seeing with some of the new drugs is a
use of lower dosages so for example with
risperidone it was tested i think it's
six milligrams 10 milligrams and 16
milligrams a lot of psychiatrists are
prescribing it at two and three
milligrams a day and actually they're
having I think fairly good results at
those low dosages so there is some
change I think that's happening that is
very encouraging at the same time having
reviewed this history I am a bit of a
skeptic about long-term results that
will result from these drugs and let's
take a lands of [ __ ] i press it is
now the best selling drug out there and
clearly some patients do find it much
more tolerable than the old drugs and
you get some clarity of thought within
with the land subpoena that you did not
get with the old drugs as well so you
can see some real benefits how are you
however you also see some real metabolic
problems with olanzapine weight gain
elevated blood sugar levels elevated
triglyceride levels you also get an
increase in dopamine receptors which we
know are problematic over the long term
if you talk to patients and there is
some of this research as well you will
also see incredible withdrawal problems
with these new drugs or some evidence in
fact that they're more problematic than
the old drugs in terms of the return of
psychotic symptoms and so my belief on
the new drugs is is we don't know what's
going to happen i just wish that we
would have good clean on a science not
biased by pharmaceutical money to give
us the best guidance on how to use them
and happen and to use them well finally
several reviewers of madden america
these are book reviews etc have taken me
to task for not providing any
alternative they said why I've done a
critique of the system of care in this
country but I've not offered any sort of
suggestion and that's true I don't
really think it's my place to do so
however I'll venture that way today I
think here's what our if you look at
this history this long history and what
you see in other countries and this
research that's been done in Sweden and
Finland and Switzerland
you do see I think an example where we
should head and in terms of what the
moral obligation of our society is
towards those who descend in a psychotic
break I think you need to have a system
and let me back up I'm sorry the thing
you see time and time again across these
various studies is that at least forty
percent of people who descend into a
schizophrenic break a psychotic break if
treated with psychosocial care but not
immediately placed on your lept Ock's do
indeed recover and then and basically
get on with their lives and I think
everybody would agree that a medication
free light if that's possible is better
than a medic a medicated life so and
that's what we saw for example in those
studies in the 1970s in each one more
than fifty percent got well and
recovered so I think you need to have a
system number one that allows that group
of patients who has a chance to descend
into a site acknowledging who has had
suffered the misery the misfortune to
descend into a psychotic break and a
schizophrenic break we need to have a
system that in some way provides them
with psychosocial care and gives them a
chance to recover and go on with a
medication free life so neither which we
night we need to start having us a form
of care that rather than one size fits
all that is more selective second you
also see in this history is that a
number of patients might have a second
episode a third episode but then in each
time will recover and go back to
premorbid status and over time frankly
get better over a longer period of
recovery we need to let that group as
well have a chance to lead eventually a
medication free life and the way that
can be done is through graduates raw
programs and it's interesting that
harvard medical researchers when they
looked at gradual withdrawal i think
they reported on this in 1998 they found
that only thirty-five percent of
patients relapsed within a six-month
period and that the remaining sixty-five
percent did well and had a good chance
of remaining well indefinitely so you
see that with graduate as opposed to
abrupt withdrawal you do indeed see
success with people getting off
and then finally of course you're going
to be left with a core group of maybe
one-third of those who suffer from a
schizophrenic break who I do believe
will benefit from continual medication
now in this country you see nothing the
sort you see no exploration no openness
to this sort of more subtle artful form
of care it is completely we're blind to
this possibility and if you suggest that
you get hammered people get really angry
that you should even suggest this there
is one country that has pursued this
sort of more artful form of care it's
Finland Finland revamped its care
starting around nineteen eighty and
here's how they respond and it's real
key you respond to the first
schizophrenic break before you start
this heavy medication i believe they
respond with a really comprehensive a
form of care what happens is they have
counseling they have vocational rehab
they have counseling for the families as
well and there they also involve
selective use of antipsychotics they're
finding that some patients do better
without drugs some patients do better
but with the drugs and they're actually
identifying patients subtypes so they
can identify who they think indeed has a
chance to recover without drugs and who
types that are going to need the drugs
fairly fairly soon I mean almost from
the get-go and I think if the reform
that we should search for is that sort
of reform where it's so I don't believe
it's drugs or no drugs I believe it's
what we need is an artful form of care
and that's really what history tells us
that's number one and the second thing I
think we really need to think about is
you need to listen to the patients and
if patients are telling you they don't
like the drugs well there may be a good
reason for that and you need to listen
to them and in the minute you deny them
that's sort of complaint or that sort of
arguments you really are denying their
experiences human being and somehow in
our care we've got to integrate
listening to the patients well I thank
you for listening to me and
thank you very much the people who are
televising and asked if you do have a
question just to wait and they'll bring
a boom down so they can record that
gentleman here so if you have a question
take anything start over here wait just
till the boom comes yes I want to thank
you for what strikes me is a very
necessary book especially given all the
bad treatment that's out there thank you
very much um I want to make allowance
for that I may not have simply heard
correctly but it does strike me though
that in your developing your critique of
psychiatry at this point you all the
instances you cited were of treatment
for schizophrenia and the medications
the neuroleptics that are in line at
least in orthodoxy as it stands for
treating that disorder and I didn't hear
a single mention of mood disorders and
for the medications that are in line to
treat those namely lithium carbamazepine
valproic acid and recently lamotrigine
coming on strong I would simply observe
that while I think you have a excellent
critique of schizophrenia that in the
absence of any evidence offered on mood
disorders that you can't really
legitimately extend your critique to
mental illness as a whole I would be
open to that I just want to know do have
evidence to make that extension um yeah
that's a good question um you know it's
a big topic it's a huge topic and of
course I wanted to remain focused on
this you know severely mentally ill and
you know the group that we once called
insane which obviously translates in
modern day times into into those
diagnosed with schizophrenia I don't
know so much about lithium a bipolar
illness I just haven't done much
research on it I have for various
reasons looked into the antidepressants
and them and you know for mood this
worse and that's a very fascinating
story it's really it's an incredible
story on real briefly i'll tell you this
you know we basically had two waves with
the with the antidepressants
antidepressants first where the
tricyclics and then the SS
our eyes well interestingly first of all
with the tricyclics the benefit over
placebo is very small it's like ten
percent or something now and it was so
small that in the 1970s there was a
number of studies run win which they
compared tricyclics to active placebo an
active perceived was something that will
cause a physiological response like dry
mouth and in seven of eight studies
there was no difference between active
placebo and the tricyclics they saw the
same improvement of you know same degree
of improvement in patients that's number
one number two the ni-mh had a extensive
trial of antidepressants you may know
this in the 1980s that had four arms to
psychotherapy arms a placebo arm which
was called good clinically no good
clinical management and a tricyclic now
at the end of six weeks there was no
difference in the remission of symptoms
in other words all groups got well
equally well in these four different
groups at the end of 18 months however
there was a difference the groups that
fared best were the two psychotherapy
groups in terms of stay well rates and
placebo and drug-treated did the worst
and they were basically the same at
around nineteen twenty percent stay well
rates and it so it wasn't very
encouraging for long-term care now what
the ni-mh did is they went back to that
data at that time and they said well we
can extract a data pool of those who are
severely depressed that it seems like
the drugs indeed have a benefit over
placebo and they basically said well
there's not a good rationale for the
mild people mildly depressed but in a
severely depressed you can make a case
that the antidepressants indeed provide
a benefit beyond placebo that's worth
well that's number one number two if you
look at the SSRI trial data one of the
things knowing that mild patients
respond so well to placebo and by the
way I need to stop here just for a
second the placebo there is a placebo
effect it's not just that in these
antidepressant trials the placebo groups
doing quite well and if they didn't
believe they were getting a medication
they wouldn't
doing so well so there is a very
positive effect from the placebo effect
that's a confounding factor so you could
say from this what we need is a therapy
that kicks in the placebo effect just
want to make that clear and the when the
drug companies did the clinical trials
for the SSRIs they deliberately excluded
the mild group because they knew it
would ruin any evidence of efficacy so
they basically had criteria only for
those severely depressed and actually
psychiatrist from Brown University
recently pointed this out you only have
evidence of efficacy for the SSRIs for
the severely depressed and not for the
mild depressed who of course are you
know the mass of people being so
prescribed so that's sort of the the
data I think that's out there the
research data i will tell you personally
I think SSRIs are a very regressive form
of intervention they don't balance
serotonin they basically perturb
serotonin function and anytime you use a
drug that chronic you you chronically
administer a drug of this sort or you
don't see great long-term results and
it's because in essence you are creating
sort of an abnormality and
neurotransmitter function the brain
tries to compensate for that by going
through various adaptations changing its
receptor density changing its serotonin
output and i'll just give an example
with the SSRIs and it sounds like you're
familiar with this you know that when
they gave SSRIs to quote healthy people
non depress people you had a lot of
sight suicidal ideation I forget what
percentage what was a 25-percent one of
four percent okay but you see you know
some you know you see problems and you
see frankly you see mania sometimes
people can't sleep these are stimulants
you can obviously psychosis result
eventually into some small number of
cases from the lack of sleep at you
sleep etc what happened with these this
history of psychotropic says we learned
how to sort of muck with the
neurotransmitters and of course that's
what we're doing but that's a profound
intervention with how the brain works
and this the thing that bugs me is that
this
be like you see the zoloft commercial
where it looks like they balance the
chemicals of the receptors that's just a
lie that's medical fraud is what that is
and I don't mean to be diminishing that
people severely depressed need help I
absolutely believe that it's terrible
thing and maybe SSRIs are good for that
group of people I just think we've sold
ourselves a story that these things
don't have costs they do have costs and
whenever you look long term you see a
lot of problematic costs and my big
worry and I think maybe you share this
is you do see some evidence of chronic
brain dysfunction low-level brain
dysfunction over time I mean maybe you
can address that but you do see it do
you dare to what's that you're the first
okay um why don't we go here okay right
yes I'm sure oh my name is Darren and if
a day I'm from Nigeria doing the night
science fellowship science John is in
fellowship at MIT I just want to speak
to your reference to an earlier study
don't have that decided Nigeria as one
of the good cases right maybe so at the
time of the study it's way worse 70s in
a teacher yeah it's it's a longer so you
know because of the downturn in the
economy and urbanization the social
structure that used to support the care
for the mentally ill is now absence
people now go about roaming the streets
Nick head until they are knocked down by
vehicles or they die of hunger or you
find them abuse you know with shaven
heads types together with their clothes
begging for money they'll be taken from
them by their handlers money they don't
benefit from and I think what is true of
that situation and i believe it's also
true of the situation here is the lack
of political liability on the part of a
mentally ill because of the very nature
of their sickness they aren't able to
organize themselves say like people
physical disability would or people
living with hiv/aids right ah
the way out which is the which is my
critical contribution here is that some
other elements in society must have to
take up that political function on their
behalf since they can do it for
themselves somebody has to mount
pressure on their part because I've been
in the US and I have seen how easily
governments at federal state level and
local easily heat budget for mental
health at the slightest excuse because
nobody will complain anyway so maybe
some elements and society will have to
take the political angle of the fight
for the welfare of the mentally ill
thank you yeah I just say real quickly
and I couldn't agree with you more I
mean of course here in the 80s we saw an
explosion of homelessness you know among
the mentally ill and that was related
related to withdrawal of social support
as well and you know knowing that
Nigeria for example has had such
upheaval in the last 15 years I don't
doubt it at all what you say is true and
these studies were done in the 70s and
80s which as you well know was a
different time and couldn't agree more i
mean you need a societal response that
begins with providing shelter fool to
empathy all those things you're talking
about how about right here my name is
Karen Walker and I've been in mental
health had my first break down at 21 and
here in the States there was a time in
the hospital when they were sadistic to
patients and some of the things that you
were saying throughout centuries when
they were sadistic to the mentally ill
sounded very sadistic but I like what
the Quakers did and I think they should
get recognition for it I'm thanking I
think the Quakers we certainly can learn
some a lot of lessons from the Quakers
in the early 1800s absolutely and then
you know the thing that I think is so
critical they always talked about the
mentally ill as brethren they didn't
talk him about his people with broken
brains they didn't talk about him as
part from humanity they talked him as
brethren and I think that this even goes
to your comments I mean that's needs to
be the guiding philosophy
and I think actually that's one of the
problems with always searching for a
biological cause you start separating
them out somehow that they're distinct
they're broke and whether or not broken
people there you know people suffer a
schizophrenic break people in distress
is what they are Judy um I'm really glad
that that you wrote the book i'm hoping
that it gets the kind of publicity that
deserves but i did notice in in the book
and in your talk and to you that it
seems like people who've been diagnosed
with mental illness are very passive and
that they need somebody to come along
and do something to them or for them and
you didn't talk at all about and this
goes also to the comment of the fellow
from nigeria the fact that there are
political organizations made up of
people who've been diagnosed with mental
illness who are trying to bring about
change and who are building coalitions
with people with physical disabilities
and other socially disadvantaged people
and that it's not just a question of
waiting for somebody else to come along
and take up this banner uh like other
groups who've been disadvantaged we're
the ones who were affected we're the
ones who have got to lead the fight you
know I agree with Judy by the way I
don't know how many of you know Judy
chamber and she's been a leader in this
movement for a long time she wrote it
she wrote a book called on our own which
you can still buy you should buy it it's
a great book it's back in print Liz one
of the things that in writing this sort
of book is is is you have to take the
argument that's being made by the
mainstream so to speak and the form of
care that's being delivered by the
mainstream I think that what you caught
self-empowerment movements this consumer
movement is a very hopeful thing a very
important thing you know they've been on
the frontlines of fighting for civil
rights for a long time making their
voice heard I regret that your voice
isn't constantly hurt in the press we
need to hear this voice absolutely it
should be every time we hear a story
about quote the mentally ill we should
be hearing from groups like yourself it
is a
a very very powerful group and important
group and you know maybe we shouldn't
even address this one of the issues
that's going on right now of course is
there's really a rollback of civil
rights of the mentor of the mentally ill
in this country you're seeing states
pass involuntary outpatient laws which
give basically the state to write to
come to your house and forcibly medicate
you which is you know that's an
incredible impingement on personal
freedom in my belief especially when you
don't have medical history of care that
shows that this leads to good quality of
life you can't even use that as the sort
of moral foundation for this force
medication in your homes and it's groups
like Judy's group and that there's a
loose coalition or maybe it's better
than a loose coalition of consumer
groups across the country that is trying
to fight this involuntary hospital
patient hospitalization and I think it
frankly is one of the most important
civil rights issues going on today
because when you see an impingement of
civil rights you're really talking about
an impingement of civil rights for
everybody i believe right behind you
will start hearing in a june Patricia
keen I didn't know how the system in
hospitals for over ten years now saying
in that state and I started taking meds
as his freshman in college and it tried
me on medications from stelazine
Thorazine some Haldol and turn before
the new drugs come out came out the only
one that work for me was held all
authority and I one on seroquel Oh with
l'occitane for my age is like partisan
I'm afraid of luck with it among the
other things along what you know and I
think again this goes to the sense that
of patients you know patient choice and
impatience a sense of what does well for
them so if the drugs are working well
that's great I mean I think that's
wonderful and and I don't think you want
a system of care that says drugs
shouldn't be used either you want you
know
want people to you want to select the
form of care and I don't think anybody
should be saying no drugs either word
say something yeah exactly and you know
there was some studies showing that
patients who most resisted that the
standard neuroleptics were the ones that
in fact have the best chance of doing
well without them sort of really
responding to them a Jew me but Jimmy by
the way half let it go ahead and
introduce him Jimmy's from Cameroon and
has had some experience with how they
take care of the mentally ill there and
I was going to make a comment here I
come from Cameroon and I'm not from the
city so I come from for me from a little
town and what I notice I mean we live
with our mentally here we don't muslims
they are not sending a hospital at all
that is one point that I want to make
but secondly it seems to me that on
arrival here that what the sort of
people that I see in my town where I
grew up who are normal that they will be
probably diagnosis as as mentally here I
said this because I said it's also too
too bad to back it on one point I've
seen a kid who is the kid this kid
relatives my mind is really i thought
the kid was very intelligent and the kid
goes in school somehow the kid was given
some drugs saying that the kid is
somehow I [ __ ] had a had a diagnosis
yeah admission disorder and I find this
really I find this very interesting and
to ask you whether there is a way to
more or less look at this sort of cases
where you just have no more people who
happens to be maybe intelligent or act
in a different manner
and somehow maybe they may be comforted
as mentally ill is there a way to
somehow to distinguish this sort of
people well you know that's a great
question with respect to this sort of
kid Adam I mean there's something may be
small but I think a lot of you can
testify that you have this kid who more
or less as I said it is the mind you
know and you've I just thought this was
a wonderful kid and somehow the teacher
stood at the kid is out of his mind well
honey I mean in my home take you to be
embraced no one will never occurred to
anybody to think that these kiddos have
no man well you know that's one of the
you know there's diagnosis is you know
that's a whole nother story which I do
address in the book I mean the diagnosis
of schizophrenia in the US became so
liberal in 1970s 1960s they were
diagnosing everybody with schizophr but
it became a very loose diagnosis so much
so that when people looked at it some
day estimated in some instances that
like four out of people four out of five
people so diagnosed really shouldn't
have been so diagnosed and that's number
one number two there is clearly you know
sort of racial and class element in the
diagnosis of schizophrenia
african-americans are much more likely
to be diagnosed with schizophrenia then
than white Americans lower classes well
are more frequently diagnosed with
schizophrenia so there is that element
and that's been found time and time
again and now what you're talking about
sort of the medicating of kids and
that's a whole nother story but clearly
we in the United States are defining
ever larger groups of behaviors as
pathological in need of medication and
you know I mean I think it's out of
control but that's just that's a little
bit away from this I mean there's no
other country in the world that's
medicating its kids like we are to the
same degree I mean it's really it's
amazing and one small thing ritalin by
the way if you want to know what it does
to the brain it acts on the brain in the
exact same way that cocaine does the
only difference is is health
fast it gets into the brain but it it
ups dopamine levels in the exact same
mechanism that cocaine does probably not
going to see the riddle and advertisers
say that right here and then over there
hi my name is Amanda Jones I work for an
organization called the Massachusetts
consumer satisfaction team and we're a
group of primarily people with mental
illnesses and family members of people
with mental illnesses who go into
hospitals and do a lot of what you're
suggesting talk to the patients or the
consumers or clients about what they
like and don't like about the services
they're getting and the medications
they're on so I applaud a lot of what
you're saying about looking into what
the people the people with mental
illnesses actually need and want however
my question is a little bit more on the
critical size I've heard I have I have
to confess I haven't read your book yet
so if this is in your book I apologize
but I know it's right on the front of
the the jacket cover and I've heard you
on NPR and other places talk about the
World Health Organization study right
and um immediately what pops to mind for
me is this comparison between developing
countries and more developed countries
was there at any matching between the
people who were being medicated or
treated in the developing countries
versus the developed countries in other
words I mean are we talking about
similar graphs of simple right or are we
talking about people who have had
different lengths or different amounts
of time since the initial onset of their
illness and different severity of
symptoms I would just think since we've
been talking so much about cultural
differences and stuff that that would
play such a large factor that would make
it very hard to compare it's a group and
I just I just know that a lot of your
critique starts out right talking about
that study and I'm just wondering about
kind of the legitimacy of no no no
that's a great question and trust me
I've heard a lot more critical stuff
that was after they did the first study
that was exactly the criticism that was
raised by basically Western doctors who
were embarrassed by this outcome clearly
i mean you know they said oh you're
you're talking about some other
diagnosis there you've misdiagnosed the
people and so that must be at their ill
with something else maybe a viral
illness or something like that and so
that's actually why they mounted the
second a comparative study was to answer
that criticism so what they did in the
second studies they is they only looked
at first episode patients okay newly
psychotic it was Western doctors doing
the diagnosis okay it was who doctors
they even so they have that control they
even divided the the group's up by
different subtypes you know both
presenting symptoms and they divided
outcomes by subtypes and what they found
is it didn't matter across different
subtypes you also saw this improve is
this better outcomes among in any
developing countries so they answered
that criticism and again it was Western
doctors doing a diagnosis but it's an
obvious point to challenge I'm Dan Craig
when I'm working with a group that I'm
inspired by Lauren Moser and Judy take
Chamberlain and is trying to create the
kinds of places that don't exist in the
United States in fact we're having a
fundraising benefit concert next month
so I'll have literature back there to
let people know about it so people can
have a home a house that's there is run
by them without having to have
medication compliance or other
institutional rules where the consumer
the people who live there establish the
rules and we're trying to raise money to
establish this house and I'd like to say
to you thank you for the work you're
doing I also have a question should I
missed the first five minutes of your
talk so I don't know if you mention this
but your article in the USA Today about
the movie A Beautiful Mind right and
with the placement of drug add
information or misleading information
into movies with the ridiculous
commercials on television Ellen
mainstream broadcast TV where you know
anxious maybe you've got a chemical
imbalance depressed of course you've got
to take our medication and it's like the
mindset is so thoroughly entrenched you
know biological human experience is now
thoroughly it's conclusive now with the
you know the genome project is it's a
you know genetic biological experience
and and that's the way way to go and
with all the money I'm just terrified
what's your response that sense of all
the money of the pharmaceutical
companies behind all that we have a
chance sure and you've actually raised
three things and maybe I can address all
of them to your latter point yeah I
think what's going on in the country
with this view of ourselves as sort of
determined by our chemistry is is a
really frightening development because
it does end up with sort of a
deterministic view of humanity that were
determined by our brain chemistry and it
doesn't leave a lot of room for free
will there's also something the sense
that well we're all supposed to be happy
aren't we were not supposed to be
anxious we're not supposed to be sad
we're not supposed to be depressed well
frankly that's what being alive often is
I mean you do feel anxiety I you feel
depression frankly I felt a lot of
anxiety at about five-thirty tonight's
didn't take a pill and I think we're
missing the sense of the spectrum of
humanity what it is like to be alive I
mean where this idea came that you're
supposed to be happy all the time I
don't it's ridiculous and you know one
of the things that you see for example I
think is just unbelievable was that in
the wake of September 11th you saw drug
companies seeking to capitalize on this
sort of free-floating anxiety and saying
this pill will make you better think of
that as a national response rather than
coming to grips with what was going on
we can take a pill to somehow make it
all go away I think that isn't so I was
going to say insane but
but you know what i mean i think it's
just it's it's an outrage and I think
it's harming us as a people to think
that and clearly you know you can go
with the kids in riddle and every
greater group of kids somehow need that
medication so that's that question the
second the first question that you
mentioned was Lauren Moser and I'll just
expand on this real briefly Warren Moshe
was head of schizophrenia studies in the
1970s he set up this experimental house
it was one of the experiments i
mentioned called satira house and the
idea was that she would go there and
frankly there was no really
professionals in the house it was they
would just get people who showed a lot
of empathy for people who weren't
frightened of people who might be going
through extreme distress and behaving in
disturbing ways and that he wanted to
see could this be a healing environment
well in fact he found that it was a
healing environment for a great number
of people but he lost his job he was
kicked out of ni-mh in essence because
of this experiment and the reason he was
is because it went against the
prevailing sort of monetary influences
that of you know related to the selling
of drugs so if you're starting such a
house all's I can say is God blessed
because it's the sort of exploration of
alternatives that I think is so
necessary and can be so welcoming by the
way do you know the birch house many
chance weren't they doing something like
that on Vermont New Hampshire but I
think it got shut down right it's closer
it got closed ran out of money which you
know and I think at the very least we
need these sort of alternatives and for
those who want that sort of alternative
and also I would like to see some sort
of science done when you get this house
so open to see how patients fair in it
the final thing you you raised the
question was about the beauty of the
movie A Beautiful Mind now what happened
with the movie those have you seen it
just before he gets his Nobel Prize he
talks about oh I'm on the newer
medications with the implication being
it's the newer medications that's helped
him get well and help them keep well
we're talking about John Nash the Nobel
economist the problem was that in truth
John Nash stop
hated the drugs stop taking the drugs in
1970 and slowly recovered thereafter so
you have this incredible fib that was
done basically to support the you know
there's a prevailing wisdom about the
merits of these drugs and I may get in
trouble with this you know National
Alliance for mentally ill even put out a
press release praising the film for
showing the vital role of recovery in
John Nash's case now I'm not saying that
that you just don't want to fib in that
way this is just an in one individual
man just let his story be as it is ana
nanak dote never tells you it's not a
referendum on drugs either way that's
just one individual response and so you
should be true to that response i
believe i right in front 30 years ago in
this state our governor discovered that
there were hideous conditions in large
mental hospitals and decided that he
would close them and open supposedly
halfway houses and these people would
have an opportunity to live in the
community and transition to the
community etc of course many of those
halfway houses did not happen and partly
as a result I'm supposing there are a
great many deeply disturbed people
living on the street and liberal
politicians sorry liberal politicians
say something like the rich as well as
the poor and the same as well as the
insane have the right to sleep under the
bridges and I'm not proud of that and I
don't enjoy stepping over people
sleeping on the greats in my city what
does Finland for example I do about
people that don't want to be treated but
definitely need help um unfortunately
don't know Finland story that well I
site Finland because it's been um I just
know that there for example Finland is
reporting that over half of its patients
descendant a schizophrenic episode get
diagnosed are holding jobs five years
out and not having psychotic symptoms
because you do have this sort of
societal wide response I think there's a
little bit of blaming the mentally ill
here in the sense I'm not talking about
you but I mean us as a society for the
the homelessness saying well they don't
want their medications and you know they
don't want to be treated what really
happened the reason we got this
explosion in homelessness in the 1980s
was the result of a social policy it
wasn't that liberal politicians went
forth and said they have the right to
forego treatment and live on the streets
that really wasn't what was going on all
that you had was you know the liberal I
guess you would say saying the right to
forgo treatments forced medication the
reason we got the explosion of
homelessness was this the
institutionalization worked in this way
in 1965 of course we passed Medicare and
Medicaid and what Medicare and Medicaid
did it allowed for the transfer of
expenses from the state to the federal
level so instead of the state's paying
for mental hospitals now the feds would
pick up that money and so what happened
is patients got basically released from
the nursing homes in excuse me from the
state hospitals into the nursing homes
that was the first step in
deinstitutionalization a second step
that really speeded this up was the 1973
act a Social Security Disability Act
because now this group of people could
get disability Social Security
disability payments welfare payments and
that could go to boarding homes as well
we got the explosion in the 1980s early
1980s under Ronald Reagan and the reason
we did is because Ronald Reagan wanted
to cut welfare rolls and he put in a
policy saying that they would have to
reestablish everybody on these rolls
reestablish their eligibility I forget
what the time period was every year
every two years and of course it was
this group that was least able to
reestablish to reestablish their
eligibility and next thing you know
their welfare payments were cut off and
they're out in the street and as you
said we never built the homes either we
never built good shelters so we never
come
we never fulfilled the promise we made
when we were going to shut down the
state hospitals to provide good shelters
carrying shelters so um you that's just
a social policy that failed at every
turn and as the gentleman here said it
shows a lack of societal response and
maybe for the gentlemen behind you of
what you sometimes hear in the consumer
groups is why should they they're tired
of waiting for a societal response and
you know they need to take it into their
own own hands because clearly and you
know what's going on with the budget
cuts now I heard the other day there's
going to be a two billion dollar
shortfall in Massachusetts in the next
budget something like that well how much
is it is it 2 billion something like
that and so you you can be sure that
mental health services are going to be
cuts they're already being cut it's the
first sort of thing targeted so we're
going away from any sort of
comprehensive commitment and this is the
amazing thing about the history here you
have in the early 1800s a poor society
really making a real commitment to
provide a you know sort of real good
shelter and and and they would even
bring in speakers to these asylums
educated speakers in fact sometimes the
entertainment at some of the early
asylums in the 1820s 1830s was seen as
the best entertainment around in terms
of académica speeches and all they had
they had you know libraries and this was
200 years ago hope I answered your
question um behind you can you wait for
the boom just was oh sure didn't
recognize your necklace my name is
Nicholas hall and worked for the
department social services I want to do
a comment and expand a little bit on
your comments regarding children I am
going to take a little creative license
and but say that it is getting fairly
close to the point where you can welcome
a third grader into the classroom by
your here's your desk use your pill of
Ritalin it's getting very close to that
and to a scary degree that what's other
the other point that's even more scary
to me though is the fact that we're
commenting on the rollback of civil
rights children have
and less ability to put input and have
input into what sort of medication they
have and are provided with and I work
primarily with adolescents and I see
kids who have been on drugs already for
10 12 years and by the time they're an
adolescent you give any adolescent
something and say here it's good for you
they're going to say screw you very much
I want a joint instead so they are going
off their meds which may or may not have
been helpful in the first place but
regardless they're going to reject that
I see that as you know it's my first
comment as a real crisis my other point
is that if we were going to manage this
more appropriately if we were going to
put in in particular for children more
in-home supportive services you touched
on the budget crunch it's not going to
happen because no one is going to be
willing in particularly you know during
a congressional and governor running
year to say oh we're going to be
spending millions more on the mentally
ill not going to happen but no one is
telling the drug companies knowingness
telling the HMOs you've got to tighten
your belts and you've got to come up
with in-home supportive services what
what is being told to them is business
as usual yeah and i think the medicaid
of children going on what you're saying
is just it's it's it's a tragedy I
really believe that Steve Hyman it was
up until recently the director of the
National Institute of Mental Health and
he published a very interesting paper
about five years ago and what he talks
about on all these drugs you end up with
perturbations in normal function such
that by the end such a son riddling you
end up with a brain and this is I think
I'm pretty much accurate that is
functioning in a manner that is
qualitatively and quantitatively
different from the normal brain so
should you be doing this to children who
can't consent ten years of ritalin I
mean I just I think that's really tragic
and for example there's one study on
ritalin about what was that they said
they had an incidence of psychosis
related to ritalin something like nine
percent one
study another study said about
twenty-five percent of the kids started
having evidence of emotional flattening
and you're right they're not consenting
to this they're not saying I want to be
on ritalin I mean it's it's it's it's
the expansion is incredible and as far
as the money forces you know one of the
problems what we have going on is we're
spending so much on prescription drugs
when every new drug is always said to be
so much better than the old drug and of
course we don't really know that that
that's actually one of the things that's
firing out of control now with health
care costs they're costly prescription
drugs and we don't really know if
they're any better than the old drugs
and of course we're expanding who who
needs to be on the drugs and and then
what happens we don't have sort of
social services for the children that
need them I I think the thing that's so
outrageous is we're a rich country I
mean we're the richest country around
and we can't provide social services i
find that outrageous um hi hi I'm Cassie
Quinlan and I've worked in been involved
with substance abuse self helped kind of
treatments and it just I mean I really
certainly the concept using the word
brethren is so important and the notion
that we've become estranged I mean when
you think of the prevailing sort of
mentality it's not only the drug
companies it's sort of the hugeness of
the organization's between media
hospitals and one of the things that
strikes me about the Met treatment of
mentally ill is how its defined
medically by the symptoms when in actual
fact I mean you've got oh I know the
young people going into adolescence
other young people going into the
workforce for the first time there are
major life transitions that are
difficult for everybody to go through
they don't it's not the same for
everybody it seems like people even in
science or even in the explanations
they're looking for a one-size-fits-all
explanation to pass around for once and
for all or something but in actual fact
it's millions of small cells of things
and I think that sometimes it's even
just the treatment the notion of
professional treatment in itself while
in
in some ways very helpful the limits of
it are just not known and to have more
things like 24-hour hotlines for various
crises just for just for just for
calling for different things for things
like I was just reading about where
they're teaching them that autistic
students and they had peer students
teaching them social skills and the
autistic students would respond to the
peers teaching them where they are so
that's just a whole dimension of your
life so Richard talking about as we all
respond to the same things in terms of
kindness empathy friendship all these
things are so necessary and way we treat
in this country or talk about it we do
talk about symptoms you have this
symptom out here as if it's a part from
the rest of your mind I think what we
are losing the thought that to be alive
is to grapple with your mind and to
grapple with your thoughts and to
grapple with your emotions and certainly
to be 7-10 1820 tues neither you know
those are transforming times and just
one quickly thing I was on Wisconsin
Public Radio yes I mentioned earlier and
I mentioned that you know these sort of
humane treatment could be healing and
someone came on a said are you actually
suggesting that kindness and friendship
can help people oh yes I am I'm gonna be
bold here so it shows how far we've gone
down this this road um I think this
actually follows up on that comment when
I'm curious on when you say people react
angrily to to your book what kind of
anger are the expressing and what is
what is motivating that well it's been
in a on the connection i had a doctor
who was quite angry with me I mean it's
really from people who you know are
psychiatrists and believe very much in
the biological psychiatry model and they
find this critique threatening I mean
there was a review in in Barron's
financial newsletter that recently
appeared that the publicist at Perseus
is afraid to show to anybody because
it's so nasty
and it's like filled with you know this
is a propaganda masquerading as fact
that sort of thing I you know it's it's
threatening to a lot of things it's
threatening to a paradigm it's
threatening to what we believe we've
come to believe this is where this is
how we see humans now and you know it's
threatening to a lot of monetary
interests as well I mean olanzapine is a
three billion dollar year drug do you
think that we're going to do any studies
to find out what the long-term negative
effects of milan's of Pienaar forget it
it's not going to happen so you know
there's a lot of money being that when
you do a crit you know the sort of
history that shows their own research
doesn't really add up people get angry
okay two more quick questions how about
Kenan in here ken just second waiting
this is I guess this is more of a
comment than I got a question I I mean
as this book is a great book and
everyone should buy it and read it it's
one of them really important
contributions of the history and
critique of psychiatry but one thing
that's been a little disappointing a
little bit in the book and also today in
our discourse I I mean for 40 years now
this critique of psychiatry has been
very well developed and essentially were
visually hearing today is the same old
discourse the same language use the
terms illness mental illness
schizophrenia this whole medicalization
of essentially psychological problems
has been thoroughly debunked now for 40
years and it does trouble me a bit that
that somehow we still find ourselves
using this discourse I mean the whole
notion of the concept of schizophrenia
has been completely debunked it's it's a
word that should never be used people
break down and suffer and are
overwhelmed and feel powerless and and
oppressed and react in all kinds of ways
that are extremely disturbing to
themselves and others but that's not
illness however we've been
almost forced by psychiatry feeding at
the trough of the drug companies to use
these kind of concepts and use this
language rather than understanding these
increasing problems that we're all
having in psychological and social and
political terms mm-hmm well I mean I
think language is your you know language
does define thinking in many ways two
things if you have sort of a mainstream
story out there you almost have to use
the language of that mainstream story to
basically even raise questions I think
so there is that limitation as you come
upon this in terms of you know the
diagnosis of schizophrenia I mean I
irony here somewhat what you're saying
is that even the believers in the
biological model will say that really we
should be talking about quote group of
schizophrenia is that there's no
discrete schizophrenia and really
there's you know sort of different types
so I mean even from the believers and in
fact Nancy and Driessen who is the
editor of the american journal of
psychiatry sort of confessed a couple
years ago I wish someone would really
wish we could figure out who really has
schizophrenia or what it is so and this
is from a mainstream broken rain person
so we're always hearing that we know
that schizophrenia is this schizophrenia
is that and it is a it really is a term
used to describe symptoms of you know
varying types actually but you know
language is tough it is a tough thing to
talk about I agree last question over
here waitress for the boom hi my name is
Carson Kookmin know I'm a first year dr.
just graduated from medical school last
year and well first of all thank you for
raising the attention to the needs of
the mentally ill so I was reading your
book and doing medical school have been
very interested in neuroscience and
still am I was wondering um reading your
book on the one hand hearing the
discussion tonight which seemed to focus
more on the society issues around how
mentally ill people are treated who gave
the example of
england where a comprehensive
psychosocial treatment get is paid for
by society is really helping people
there on the one hand these facts and on
the other hand as i was reading the
final chapters of your book it seemed
very much like saying how bad
psychiatrists and scientists are and how
they are doing bad science and there may
be problems there although only on the
other hand just to give one example you
inside a Martin Keller as a psychiatrist
who receives an enormous amounts of
grants and the New England Journal of
Medicine would have had difficulties in
finding somebody who could write an
editorial f29 depressants yes yes and I
mean the study that he published was
that psychotherapy and antidepressants
are more effective than either food
alone which was a pretty benign finding
just by itself and not like for the fam
cook on pharmaceutical industry so my
question is um why is the subtitle of
your book starting with bad signs bad
medicine and why don't you raise a
little bit more attention for the
society effects which seem to be from my
point of view the major problem that's a
great question I guess the answer to
that is this um you know there's the
widespread recognition I think in the
country that our social care has fallen
down of the mentally ill and has for
some time the question is then and and
that's sort of accepted so the common
wisdom is that our medical care is good
our social care is bad and if you can
write that story you'll be applauded by
you know the mainstream psychiatry the
prov the reason is but the question is
then and go back to the who studies it
wasn't just the u.s. that had the poor
outcomes it was other countries with
incredible social support system that
had the bad outcomes as well and and why
was that say you know England Japan
Czechoslovakia
and frankly I think that you really do
have to focus in on the medicine at
least as it was under the old drugs
because you do see that the medical
model itself produced this chronicity
and produce this change in you know
basically the super sensitivity to
psychosis and frankly that becomes a
real biological problem that you have to
confront now the title for bad science
bad medicine is because and by the way I
didn't really want to condemn psychiatry
as a whole by the way I think a good
psychiatrist a good therapeutic
relationship well there's plenty of
people tell you that's a very healthy
healing relationship it can be a
wonderful relationship now does that do
we have a society set up today to
further that relationship no really
psychiatrists are paid to prescribe
pills today the reason for bad science
bad medicine is because when we saw
studies for example which did have
better outcomes with this sort of non
drug or selective care whether the moral
responsibility at that point is to
explore that alternative that is the
scientific responsibility that's number
one number two if you have a scientific
finding for example that you hypothesize
that too many dopamine receptors lends
itself to psychosis and if you find in
science that they don't have this
abnormality before they're medicated and
they do have it after medicated that is
an obligation to respond to that from a
scientific point of view what did we do
we just kept on lying we just kept on
saying they had too much you can read
about it for year after year too much
dopamine over activity that's the bad
science in the bad medicine because we
didn't explore the scientific findings
we and that's what good science is and
and and bad science with the new drug
trials you don't buy a studies and I got
we got to get out we don't bias studies
to make the new drugs look better than
old drugs that's bad science and
actually here's the thing is I'm a
believer in science I love science I
love the scientific approach and
actually one of the things I feel
betrayed by is in fact that you don't
see that here you don't see this
willingness to go where your own
findings are taking you
and so when Lauren Moser finds better
outcomes with sotiria house don't we
have a moral obligation even from a
scientific point of view to further that
experiment I would argue we do and yet
we didn't we just shut it down so that's
the reason for that title we need to
follow thanks very much
sorry went along
bobble the upstairs signing books right
now
robert whittaker is author of madden
america bad science bad medicine and the
enduring mistreatment of the mentally
ill